welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and will Marvel Studios recast Kang
the Conqueror after firing Jonathan
Majors with a new actor like colan
Domingo or will they move away from the
character of Kang completely and shift
the franchise to villains like Dr Doom
in this video I'm going to explain how
all this drama over Kang the Conqueror
while certainly largely to blame on the
actor's legal issues is also something
that happened within the Studio's
uniquely odd creative strategy so would
recasting Kang actually fix the
character in the MCU I was out on
paternity leave when all this stuff went
down last month and I think I just owe
you guys my take on it but I think it's
been a good thing cuz we've had a couple
weeks to just clear our heads and just
really think about what's going on here
so the latest news is that Coleman
Domingo who many of you know from fear
of The Walking Dead Or Euphoria is the
latest actor speculated to take on the
role of Kang first claimed by scooper
Daniel rpk Coleman is 20 years older
than Jonathan majors and Coleman Domingo
has a long history of roles on stage and
screen and someone you could definitely
see as a more experienced Kang Prime
variant who has avoided the pitfalls and
absorbed the knowledge of of all other
more Reckless kangs of the dynasty
actually in a 2021 interview with Awards
watch dingo actually said he wanted to
be a Marvel villain when it comes to the
Marvel of DC I'm like I think I'm ready
now you know I'm worked out fit I think
I want to play a villain I just wanted
to be the villain I don't want to be the
good guy I actually want to do some
really nasty dirty work and yeah saying
hey figy put me in your stuff is
something all actors say at some point
in interviews this is just kind of
lining up perfectly in the way that
interviews with David gornet saying that
he wanted to play Superman felt weeks
before he was officially announced in
the role and not for nothing MCU actor
Ginger Gonzaga who played Nikki on
She-Hulk tweeted her support for Domingo
in the role of Kang but let's talk about
the elephant in the room here December
18 2023 Jonathan Majors was found guilty
of one count of Reckless assault in the
third degree and one charge of
harassment following a March 25th 2023
incident in which he was arrested after
a domestic dispute with his then partner
Grace Jabari a dancer and movement coach
whom Majors met while working on Ant-Man
the wasana Mania Majors was acquitted on
another charge of assault and a charge
of aggravated harass harassment but his
sentencing for the two charges he was
found guilty for is set on February 6th
and on the day of his conviction Marvel
Studios dropped Majors from the role of
Kang they made no announcements of who
would replace him or whether he would be
replaced but according to the Hollywood
Reporter internally Marvel Studios has
begun to refer to the previously
announced Avengers the King Dynasty to
Avengers 5 now you may have noticed that
throughout 2023 we were pretty hesitant
to cover any step of this Jonathan
Major's trial and that's because my
background and my education was in
journalism and journalist operate under
very specific guidance when it comes to
discussing an alleged crime before the
verdict you have to refer to all actions
as alleged you have to cite specific
sources like police reports you have to
be careful about framing statements from
lawyers as fact as they will sometimes
make bogus claims to sway the public to
their side and to try to play it out in
the media you don't want to be part of
it as an independent media Outlet you
just don't want to play a part in
helping either the prosecution or the
defense now yeah there's a whole
industry of Nancy Graces out there but
that's not what new Rockstar does and I
think it's just kind of dangerous when
social media influencers with big
followings but no real background in law
or in journalism just start commenting
on these Court proceedings while they're
still in progress because this stuff is
so messy and we don't have all the
details and even relaying who said what
or showing footage any of that can cause
harm that you don't intend people love
drama and a lot of outlets saw High
engagement from the Johnny Depp Amber
herd trial and they may claim that
they're just reporting entertainment
news but like play forplay coverage of
declaring Jonathan major is wrongfully
accused one week and then the next week
declaring him a horrible person based on
something he said or might have said in
a private argument I don't know just
talking about that stuff tends to bring
out the most conspiratorial the most
ignorant and just the generally worst in
people and new rockstars is not going to
play that game now I don't blame you for
being interested in it but serious
Outlets should hold themselves to a
higher standard now a verdict changes
things journalistically because the jury
has now found Majors to be guilty of
those two counts Reckless assault in the
third degree and of harassment and he
has been convicted and those are
objective facts that we can freely
report now I'm not going to get into all
of Jonathan Major's personal drama but
part of the reason this was such a mess
for Marvel Studios is because the studio
operates under a principle of actor
equals role aside from a few recasts in
Phase One like Terence Howard to Don
Cheeto as James rhods Edward Norton to
Mark Ruffalo as Bruce Banner and lower
profile recastings of younger characters
like Cassie Lang going from Abby forson
to Emma Furman to Katherine Newton in
the MCU they tend to never recast major
roles Iron Man always looks and sounds
like Robert Downey Jr Doctor Strange
always looks and sounds like Benedict
Cumberbatch Scarlet Witch always looks
and sounds like Elizabeth olssen whether
it's in an episode of what if or a
costume character at a Disney park or an
action figure that you buy at the gift
shop Marvel Studios insists on
continuity of likeness they want to own
these faces so that they can reuse them
like toys in a sandbox actually Marvel
Studios is so insistent on continuity
that on Whata if which is a beautifully
animated series The Studio forced the
character designs to resemble the
liveaction likenesses of people like
Chris Evans Paul Rudd Jeremy rener
Sebastian Stan and other dudes of
similar complexions and when these
characters are clean shaven and not
talking and wearing anything other than
their super suits it is impossible to
know who they are like you cannot look
at that season 3 promo and tell me that
Alexi there looks like David Harbor
nuh-uh no way oh one shot energy huh I
think I'll try
[Applause]
it
so what does one shot's Focus Sho
[Music]
do
turn
wa so uh one shot really is all you need
begin your transformation with onot
energy today by going to oneshot
energy.com
new rock stars for 10% off your order
but Marvel and Disney do this because
character continuity is profitable
through toys print publishing apparel
costume characters at Disney Parks the
studio makes a lot more money if they
can say that the Iron Man you saw in the
movie is the same Iron Man that you made
at Disney Land and the same Iron Man
action figure that you buy in the gift
shop actually speaking of Iron Man the
studio fell into this practice back in
the early days when Kevin feige and John
Fabro hired Robert Danny Jr to play Tony
Stark and Iron Man Robert Danny Jr's
personal history with substance abuse in
the previous decade gave him a bit of a
reputation as damaged goods in Hollywood
in the early OTS and it wasn't really
until films like Kiss Kiss Bang Bang
that Hollywood began to see him as
someone that they could work with again
casting him as Tony Stark was seen as a
risk but a risk that absolutely paid off
as audiences saw some authenticity in
Downey's performance as a problematic
playboy turned Redemptive hero in many
people's eyes Tony Stark was Robert
Downey Jr and Robert Downey Jr was Tony
Stark but to build a Cinematic Universe
around that base Marvel Studios had to
pay up according to the book MCU the ROM
Marvel Studios by Jo Robinson Dave
Gonzalez and Gavin Edwards Downey signed
a one-off contract for just $500,000 for
the first Iron Man but for Iron Man 2 he
Inked a new deal in the neighborhood of
$10 million and committed to an Avengers
film Beyond that for another 10 million
plus a cut of the profits and this
profit sharing is where Robert dunny Jr
raed it in because from the first
Avengers movie he made about $50 million
and then he made $70 million after a
similar deal for Iron Man 3 and then a
similar deal for Captain America Civil
War $64 million and for Infinity war and
endgame Robert dowy Jr made $75 million
for each of those movies now Marvel
Studios obviously couldn't afford doing
this with every actor so they adopted a
more frugal approach with all the other
actors and their roster signing them
upfront for nine picture deals this was
actually a business practice from the
old Hollywood movie studio system from
the 1920s to the 1960s Hollywood Studios
would select promising young actors and
condition them into stars that they
would effectively own and cast in all of
their movies Judy Garland for example
had such a contract with MGM and Garland
said that with that control over her
life the studio got her addicted to
uppers and downers it kept her on a
cruel diet and stole her youth now
nowadays such contracts aren't nearly as
restrictive for actors they aren't
exclusive agencies and labor unions have
scored more protections for the actors
and really the risk of long-term
contracts like that and prioritizing
likeness continuity Falls more on the
studio like Marvel like if an actor
would have to drop out of a role due to
health or legal issues for viewers that
character would also be dead in the
universe now Kang the Conqueror could
have been less of a risk for the studio
as a character has taken on multiple
identities and appearances throughout
the comics but in that mid-credit scene
of Ant-Man the wats quamania they double
down on the approach and they put
Jonathan majors in dozens of different
costumes to suggest that he would be
playing every incarnation of Kang in the
MCU so now with Jonathan Major's firing
after his guilty verdict should Marvel
Studios reset and move away from Kang
all together no I don't think so they've
already invested heavily in this
character character through the Loki
series which is really the best thing to
come out of Marvel's Multiverse Saga and
we still need to see Kang kill some
Avengers in alternate timelines but even
before Major's legal drama the character
of Kang was so far written in the MCU to
be predecessors to the final form and
there in lies the opportunity with
recasting Kang Marvel fans are ready to
meet a final form they are ready for the
real Kang and that real Kang doesn't
have to be played by Majors with a new
actor like Coleman Domingo playing a k
Prime 20 years older than Majors it
could be implied that this is just an
older version of Nathaniel Richards with
more life experience more scars more
secrets and more regrets the kind of
parts of a character that you don't see
as much of in a younger man Kang Prime
needs to be distinct from all other
kangs for skeptical viewers to see him
as a greater threat than the other fors
that have been defeated by like
spaghettification and ants also by
recasting Kang Marvel Studios would
finally break its no recasting precedent
the MCU needs a new tala a new Tony
Stark new X-Men and we shouldn't have to
wait until 2030 to get them a bold
recasting of the universe's big bad
would prove audiences are capable of
understanding actors are playing roles
and are not themselves superheroes and
super villains so I want to thank you
all for your patience as we waited for
me to return from paternity leave to
discuss this it's a sensitive topic we
didn't want to rush a video out but
please support new rockstars by
subscribing to all three channels in the
new rockar network for analysis and
insight into everything you love thanks
for watching
bye
[Music]
he
hey
[Music]
heyy